on confond souvent cette herbe
aromatique avec le fenouil
elle dégage la même senteurs anisé
mélanie ce créole dispose de nombreuses
propriétés médicinales
sa floraison forme de grandes poubelles
qui portent de petites fleurs jaunes
ce sont principalement les graines et
les racines qui sont utilisées en
médecine traditionnelle mais à la
réunion ce sont les feuilles qui servent
à la préparation des tisanes l'anis la
titanic rêve vraiment là c'est bien
content parce que depuis le temps mais
cette plante l'anis et là cette année
années passées à planter salem un bon
petit carreau l'anis que la poussée très
connu dans toute la réunion entière
comme la pana comme citronnelle comme
les ébats book comme le flat l'anis ses
plans d'un jardin se retrouve pas dans
la nature
voilà où le parfum d'anis et ne remette
en forme ici lâche là ni les très très
apprécié très demandé pour la digestion
pour les coliques des enfants des bébés
donc ces petites branches dany comme ça
pour deux tasses trois tasses pour un
adulte avec il ya pana justement il y
associer avec la pana et pour les bébés
un petit peu d'analystes comme ça que
nous va mettre dans une petite tisane
temps bave et pour les coliques les
petits bébés qui avaient pas dormir le
soir qui plats qu'ils aient mis c'est
avec un petit vent qui fait mal ça avec
la pana un petit code pêche c'est connu
pour la tisane pour apaiser les mamans
et les enfants à ne pas abuser par ce
que
en excès la neil hayes peu fait vomi ma
radio
kita fusion diana hédoniste bien manger
là et il va boire ça juste après pour
bien digérer voit la petite tisane ait
fana et alice à nice bien mélanger la
peut rajouter un petit peu d'argent là
dedans
il fera pas de mal voilà il ya cinq six
personnes n'avaient à la dose pour 5 6
personnes il va mettre ça dans un petit
récipient l'un pour verser là dessus de
l'eau que la bourriche de l'essonne
chaude seul bon on va laisser ça voilà
la plante ne commencent à changer de
couleur la voix bien et ça commence à
être parfumée aussi on sent un bonne
tisane
l'inclusion 20 minutes que trois petites
tasses et on boit ça on apprécie sa
après un bon repas à nice reconnaître
aussi que c'est bon pour les problèmes
de mauvaises manies des gens qui
marchent où ils effeuillent de danis
pousse à l'anis lorsqu'on prend ça les
mamans qui allaitent comme le fenouil le
à nice y aide pour faire monter les
l'anis
il met sa bon peu dans des préparations
aussi de cuisine de matani ici ne
trouvera pas dans 10 pays en grains mais
les personnes qui utiliseraient des
graines d'anis
il faudrait peut-être prendre peu de
grain pour faire une infusion donc en
pharmacie se trouvent des graines d'anis
la celanese fresque qui trouve aussi
beaucoup sur le marché forain des
personnes ils plantèrent de la jordanie
zaiter dans les eaux et ils viennent
avec ses immenses forêts en vendant des
petits paquets à nice comme ça pas cher
pour un euro mais pas que la liste comme
ça est devenue une trouve votre compte
pour faire le petit tisane voilà ce que
nous peut dire sur un disciple
facilement dans les eaux c'est vrai mais
moi explique est peut être trop la main
pour ça et me crois tu m'as trouvé dame
à semer les graines un match au goût de
graines dans les bars et moon dans un
pied avec des graines à semer manger
petits carreaux ce n'est donc à nice
votre taille a lui aussi une fois qu'il
a une fois qu'il a bien poussé là il
faut pas hésiter à y aller parce que les
tiges qui montent comme sa rivale à
dessécher et pour vous lire beau jaune
et est il donc faute à yannick à ne pas
confondre à nice et fenouil c'est la
même famille mais fenouil sur une bulle
dessous comme ça on dit soit tu voi à
nice à la pointe bull à tiji monde
droite comme ça herbert est bien bien
bien un coaster la tige mais là point de
bulbes lapointe d'épaisseur de bulles
tsunami donc c'est la nuit créole vrai
petit van hyst
je dois venir précis bien